no you have to let it sit for I think it
was 140 seconds I think it is in the
interest of the shoot I think we might
have to not wait the 140 seconds but
then the interest of me being Irish we
have
to wait
that's a very English outlook on things
let the guy settle
hi I'm Niall Horan and this is snack
Wars UK versus Ireland for lab Bible
we're doing Ireland today because guess
what
spoiler alert I'm Irish
[Music]
oh I hate cucumber
so that's already lost we'll have to eat
it yeah dude don't they cucumber
coriander avocado probably my three
least favorite things in the world all
right here we go I know I'm gonna hate
this
oh
hey cucumber the texture of
oh that's just terrific I feel like the
the bread and the butter make it 100
times better like cucumber on its own
it's not great that's horrific now what
we got here chicken fillet roll so
basically chicken fillet roll in Ireland
is like
yeah it's a thing that we're absolutely
obsessed with I get one all the time
when I go home grab a chicken generally
and then fillings of your choice you can
have plain chicken or spicy chicken I go
for a spicy have like lettuce cheese
the sweet chili corn sometimes and
they're in our petrol stations so on
this one we've got a bit of lettuce
we've got a bit Mayo uh chicken cheese
here we go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
good
red stuff yeah you can't beat that it's
just beautiful it's so simple but so
effective how does it compare to the
Irish petrol station surgeons
um you're weren't close but it was a
good attempt they appreciate the attempt
yeah the chicken fillet roll wins every
time I also hate cucumbers it never had
a chance poor cucumber hey
okay we've got Scotland's number one
tenants I don't think I've ever had
tenants but Capaldi's always on a bird
he said it's lovely we'll try this one
first because we know who's winning this
I am a larger fan
oh I can have the glass absolutely you
can yeah is that no no please do we have
many of them 45 degree angle
and just as we get to the logo here I'll
start to shape up
oh wow I know my way around
right okay oh that's a color isn't it
it's nice and cold
not terrible I'd say if you had five or
six of them you'd know about it it's
definitely gone flat like straight away
which is not good right next one
Guinness
the real deal this is a Nitro surge as
well uh Guinness came up with the idea
to make sure that when you pour out of a
can you get as close to what you would
get in the pub as possible and you do a
two-part pour like you're meant to you
just get it and do the same again
45 degrees
no you have to let it sit for I think it
was 140 something seconds I think it is
in the interest of the shoot I think we
might have to not wait the 140 seconds
well in the interest of me being Irish
we have
we have to wait
that's a very English outlook on things
let the guy settle that's a healthy
looking Point again and then you just
hold it straight and I actually think
you've the tip it backwards like this
just left a little Dome come over the
top
oh I've overspilled it
feel looks beautiful
it looks I've made a mess there
I apologize to people all over Ireland
for that and then you just kind of let
it settle there just watch as it does
its absolute magic it's just a thing of
beauty isn't it it's just there's not
many drinks that you sit there and gojis
that's beautiful Guinness in Ireland is
on a different level I actually thought
it was a myth before I moved and then
drank Guinness everywhere else and
realized um that it is it's not great
worldwide just you need to take care of
it it's not 100 ready but for the
purpose of the shoot
for her
we'll uh we'll drink it right here we go
good one
[Laughter]
Big Win there for the Irish I think that
is the best pool we've had on snack Wars
yeah I have the shakes out a few of them
yesterday
[Music]
oh that was well done I was like Dynamo
she's got a great sleight of hand all
right here we go
[Music]
right love hearts and clove drops
to be honest with you not even sure
which one's Irish from which one's
British
yeah yeah I know what I'm joking
this is the most Irish thing of all time
this is very like your grannies eat them
yeah I do love
love hearts as well to be fair let's see
what we see if we get any good ones
today
yeah still a pain in the ass to get out
of Jesus Christ
the tenant is repeating on me
all right
Epic
[Laughter]
good yeah
they're still decent but still chalky
um the next one is they're doing them
with the Emojis now it's not just words
of affirmation taking the Nostalgia of
it moving into the 21st century leave
them where they were they're good
right here we go
12 drops
imagine like a bottle of banolin or
something like that a mucus reliever
in a squeeze
that's what this smell like
oh my God yeah they're very clovy
um it's easier not great at all honestly
what were we doing
like a horrible Fisherman's friend yeah
and that's saying something UK have to
win this one I'm afraid the love hearts
are staple and the club drops are a
staple that we could do get rid of yeah
[Music]
let's have a look
fish and chips I assume this is peas
y Peas I hate peas
they're one of very few veg that
actually taste like the ground if I can
get fish and chips I'm getting beans
oh so this is just chips Jack the
chipper looks decent though I'll eat
I'll eat the peas with you I don't like
like that doesn't even look like peas
but let's not dig out Jack the chipper
he's trying his best I think chips cover
both UK and Ireland to be honest but
they're good chips then yeah I don't
know
it chips your favorite like form of
potato
yeah let's get into it we like them
roasted we like the mashed as I said we
do live up to The Stereotype I like
innocent I like potatoes
that was good
didn't really taste the mushy pieces the
chips were that good
they're decent chips but by the way this
is uh probably lots of like cabbage and
mash What's this called there's a nope
Cannon
Mash I think it is cabbage mashed potato
yeah my granny used to do this
um yeah when we were younger
yeah that's very good actually to be
fair
what would your granny serve that would
um any of the meats gravy
and sometimes of pie I'm going in again
oh wow please do
oh my God they're both really good it's
a tough call just a Nostalgia alone
I would lean towards cabbage or Mash or
whatever we're calling it if there was a
bit of fish in there now I'd have to
have a rethink but you messed up Final
Round
[Music]
oh but fast versus Bailey's okay book
Fast tonic wine
and there's always a good memory about
the book first uh I remember being at um
the Brits and it was presented Lewis
uh an award and I remember like sitting
at the table next to him and him he had
like three or four of his mates from
Glasgow down and they were just gonna
walk around with individual bottles of
book perhaps handed out to everyone
at the Brit Awards was like fine dining
and like red white wine and buckets at
the table and there's the lads from
Glasgow were down and they've got
bottles of buckets drank a Bucky
um so yeah I'm I am uh familiar
with the book first
oh
Christ
y all right yeah yeah you can have you
can have a glass or two of it but after
that no that's
um
yeah
Bailey's my mother's favorite she loves
it yeah it's Grand I look I love
Bailey's I do
this is uh kind of yeah your digestive
depends on where in Europe you're from
um yeah so all right bookies beforehand
I don't know if I'd be having like a
bottle of bug fast before my dinner
um and then lovely Baileys which is
lovely Irish cream liqueur
yeah that's lovely that I'm gonna have
to go with Bailey's yeah I'm sweating
now there was a lot of drinking and
eating sugar Island one
hi I'm Niall Horan and this is snack
Wars UK versus Ireland for Life lid
Bible
hi I'm Louis Tomlinson and you're
watching snack Wars UK versus us on lab
Bible
oh
whiskey
is this gin yeah you know gin's nasty so
let's start with the uh start with the
chin do people love ice would you I
think so yeah yeah